[Music]
hi there I'm Jimmy and I'm Heather we're
here to launch a new series focusing a
Google cloud will showcase some
interactive demos and labs and discuss
different GCP products with experts
that's right our first topic to kick off
this series is around I am or identity
access management let's get to it
identity access management as how you
decide who can do what with your Google
cloud resources you can get incredibly
specific when you create an I am policy
but essentially you have an identity a
role and a resource think of it as an
air traffic controller for your business
an organization's internal structure and
policies can get complex fast projects
workgroups and managing who has
authorization to do what can change
dynamically cloud iam is designed with a
clean Universal interface so you're able
to manage access control across all
Google cloud platform resources
consistently from App Engine the GCE
keep in mind cloud AM is offered at no
additional charge for GCP customers you
will only be charged for use of other
services ah geez sweet my roots you know
it feels like yesterday when we're just
doing Jimmy we got a lot to cover okay
fine
speaking of G sweet cloud I am supports
standard Google accounts that means you
can manage users and groups through the
Google admin console all in one place
you can create cloud i.m policies
granting permission to a Google Group a
Google hosted domain a service account
or specific Google account holders using
cloud identity
a full audit trail permissions
authorization removal and delegation is
surfaced automatically for your admins
cloud I am lets you focus on business
policies around your resources and makes
compliance easy for established
enterprises with complex organizational
structures hundreds of workgroups and
potentially many more projects cloud iam
provides a unified view into security
policy across your entire organization
with built-in auditing to ease
compliance processes and now the fun
part quick laps as a part of this series
will highlight a demo or lab of each
product or use case we discuss we want
you to get your hands dirty by
experimenting with the products
themselves so we have quick lab
environments set up for your testing you
can check out the link to start to click
lab yourself here keep in mind these
take about a half hour or more let's
jump into the lab we're joining the lab
at the section where user one removes
project access from user to this task
easily shows how to add and remove
permissions to a user here's what
happens at this point in the lab as user
one you have a Google Cloud Storage
bucket user 2 currently has access to
the file
now as user 1 remove user twos
permissions as user - try to access the
file and fail now back to user 1 give
user 2 permission to view the bucket
finally as user to access the bucket
well that's all the time we have for
today we hope you enjoy this series and
would love to hear more about how you
use or would use cloud identity access
management at your business that's right
and you can learn more through our
on-air webinar series quick labs and our
blog all the links are below also make
sure to check out Google clouds on
demand courses on Coursera thanks for
watching
[Music]
you